this is a production of Cornell
University
okay thank you Kevin I'm going to
continue our discussion of kicker popipo
and talk about the work that I've been
doing looking at resistance to the
disease fight after a crown and root rot
so the causal agent of this disease is
fight off the reCAPTCHA C which infects
a wide variety of plants including many
economically important vegetable crops
such as most Sala nation species all
cucurbits and some legumes as well which
other campesi can infect all plant
organs and causes different symptoms the
most important of which I'm showing on
this slide we see fruit rot on the left
the white growth that you see is the
pathogen sporulating and I'm focusing on
crown and root rat symptoms of which we
see on the right common root rot causes
dampening off symptoms and young
seedlings but also affects more mature
plants causing lesions on the roots and
stems which lead to wilting and plant
death so in pepper there are sources of
very high disease resistance that are
used in breeding and there have been
there's been a lot of work looking at
the genetics of disease resistance but
much less is known in orbit acá although
many accessions many urban species have
been screened for either fur trap
resistance or root and Crown rot
resistance and there's a wide amount of
variation in terms of degree of
acceptability although there are very
few cases of cleared complete resistance
to the pathogen so my work is focused on
Cucurbita pepo which as we learned more
in include zucchini and pumpkin among
other market classes of squash and I
think people there are no sources of
complete resistance to this disease that
have been identified and most cultivars
are highly susceptible to light after a
rubyprogram
so here at Cornell in the Missouri lab
in recent years there's been work to
develop pumpkin and zucchini lines with
an increased amount of resistance to fit
under it crown and regret and the most
promising lines which I'm working with
for my research were derived from across
between zucchini cultivar Romulus and a
gray zucchini landrace from a national
plant germplasm system in the picture we
can see on the Left one of the advanced
lines compared to susceptible zucchini
fratty Dungey and these advanced lines
are partially resistant in that disease
program progresses more slowly and
symptoms are reduced but we still
observe plant mortality on many plants
of these genotypes
however they perform better than the
topic sessions from a previous study
that evaluated several hundred different
people germ plasm equations i've also
challenged these breeding lines with
seven diverse pathogen isolates and the
response to disease is consistent
indicating the absence of any isolate
specific interactions so one of the
goals of my research is to identify
low-side that control resistance to
photographer crown and regret and do
that I've developed an F to matthew
population we can see the parents and
the f1 on the left that's acceptable
parent is zucchini variety Dungey in the
middle we have the breeding line that I
previously identified as being most
resistant and on the right is the f1 the
figure on the right shows area under the
disease progress curve on the parents
and f1 area under the news progress
curve is a measurement of disease
progression over time in this case using
measurements of disease incidents every
other day for two three weeks following
inoculation we can see that f1 is not
intermediate between the parents but is
closer in phenotype to the sensible
parent and we can also see that the
differences between the parents are
robust to
differences in the mountain
concentration where even evacuating
partially resistant parent with
suspension of a hundred thousand zones
first four mill we observe less disease
than on the susceptible parent
inoculated with a suspension of 1000 per
mil so we expect the genetic
architecture of this trait to be complex
and with that in mind we are employing
Volks aggregate analysis with all
generally sequencing of the books to map
QTL the idea behind this is
straightforward the consists of
evaluating a large number of plants
identifying the phenotypic extremes in
this case the most susceptible and the
most resistant sequencing those DNA
pools from those bulks estimating allele
frequencies genome-wide and identifying
regions that if between the books so
there can be several advantages in some
cases over traditional QTL mapping where
all individuals are phenotyped and gene
typed separately that is because your
gene typing fear and vidual x' gene
typing costs are lesser phenotyping is
also simpler in the sense that instead
of assigning a precise if is explored
all individuals it just requires the
researcher to identify the fugitive
extremes there can be a statistical
challenge in separating signal in allele
frequency differences between bulks from
sampling noise from sequencing but
several methods have been developed that
increase the accuracy of allele
frequency estimates at snips by
borrowing information from neighboring
murders so this slide shows how I
implemented this approach in the f2
population I mentioned earlier I
evaluated over 13,000 f2 seedlings I
sprang them with a suspension of taffeta
cap to see those cores and identified
bulks not just as acceptable and
resistant but also a random bulk to
estimate baseline allele frequencies in
the population and attempted to have the
books
15% of the population selection was
applied in each 72 cell trade the plants
were so did so that corresponds to 11
plants in each tray being selected for
the books and then tissue from for the
plants was poked DNA was extracted and
I'm currently quantifying it and
standardizing across 96 trays to end up
with 6 DNA pools the 3 books from both
stages of phenotyping that will shortly
be submitted for sequencing I'm also
interested in the mechanisms that allow
plants of these partially resistant gene
types to have a higher probability of
survival compared to other gene types
and previous work has shown that
structural and physical features in
roots and stems are involved in
resistance to fight African root rot and
a previous experiment using peppers
showed that pethor catalyst Ezell spores
were able to attach to and germinate
equally on roots of both acceptable and
resistance efforts septal peppers the
pathogen was able to penetrate into the
interior of resistant gene types growth
was limited to the outer cell layers of
the cortex so this summer with the help
of undergraduate interns who worked on
this project we used a green fluorescent
protein tagged isolate and on follicle
laser scanning microscopy to look at the
infection process in both one of our
partially resistant breeding lines 1709
and the susceptible teeny variety gunga
we looked at 96 taproot cross-sections
and gave them a binary score of -
present or absent in route interiors and
in the vascular tissue and both 3 days
post inoculation and 6 days post
inoculation we observed higher
probability observing high peak in
either the interior or the vascular
tissue in our sensible rat dungeon but
we still observed -
intentional portion of parsley resistant
breeding lines and I think this is
interesting because whereas in the
greenhouse we observed almost all of the
dungeon plans to be dead by seven days
post inoculation by a couple of weeks
post inoculation we only deserved a 20%
the partial we resistant bring line to
be dead although we observed many more
of the plants to have pathogen present
in the interior of the route so it seems
that penetration the pathogen is limited
in the personally resistant gene type
and that the plants able to continue to
grow and survive despite infection
compared to the susceptible variety so
my next steps are currently developing
additional method populations that I
will use to validate any QTL that I'm
able to detect in the books arrogant
experiment and to estimate their effects
and I also hope to continue to do some
additional microscopy experiments and
differential gene expression analysis to
further understand what makes a
resistant plant more resistant so with
that I'd like to thank the smart and
Core labs my other members of my
committee
Michael is Erick and Philip Messer Carla
plant in Missouri lab who I collaborate
with from these projects ignition and
smart lab Holly Lang Ella Reeves was the
undergraduate who worked on the
microscope experiments and funding from
a New York State Department of
Agriculture and markets before you know
it seems like you that board
diversification or I mean other issues
specific resistance like being issued to
there's there's evidence in pepper for
very specific resistance there's there's
not much evidence in tributes I
evaluated I looked at response these are
some distant Alliance mostly its
horizons from New York but also a couple
isil's from the west coast and the
response was the same in all cases
plants died do you have any idea what
the difference is in those plants was
there for IV or or just what the cause
was I I don't know in part I think
there's there's kind of maybe a
threshold in terms of infection and
there's variation in terms of how many
plants of the same gene type reach that
threshold and end up dying and we see
that in pepper as well but I'm
interested in maybe using quantitative
PCR to try to estimate adjoin abundance
and associate that with survival there's
no more questions
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu